مع دخولنا العام الجديد ،
أصبحت شعبية اللعبة بين الشباب
موضوعًا كبيرًا كما كان دائمًا ،
ويتطلع أحد أفضل اللاعبين في العالم للعب دوره
في تطوير اللعبة التي
تمتع تومي فليتوود بالعودة في الوقت المناسب
إلى الشكل في عام 2022 بالفوز على DP
جولة حول العالم وحققت اثنين من أفضل خمس نهائيات كبرى
لم ألعب بشكل جيد في عام 2021 ، أعتقد
أنني اتخذت ما هو خطأ وأعتقد أنني
أخذت ما تعلمناه من أنني قمت
بتطبيقه على هذا العام وقمت به  بالتأكيد لقد
فعلت المزيد من الأشياء الصحيحة
وعملت في الاتجاه الصحيح
وكان من الرائع أن استمتعت
برحلة التحسين مرة أخرى
والعمل على لعبتي والشعور
بثقة أكبر في موسم مليء
نقاط عالية يحدد فليتوود
حصوله على المركز الرابع في البطولة المفتوحة رقم 150
على أرض الجولف ، حيث ستكون
لحظة لن ينسى فيها أبدًا أن افتتاح المركز 150
في سانت أندروز سيكون دائمًا
مثل هذا الافتتاح الخاص وأعتقد أن
الجميع كان متحمسًا للغاية  أن أكون جزءًا
منه لشخص ما ، ناهيك عن التنافس هنا فقط ،
وأكمل عطلة نهاية الأسبوع وأكون
هناك يوم الأحد في محاولة للوصول إلى
قمة قائمة المتصدرين ،
اعتقدت أن الجو كان رائعًا
وأعتقد أن  open هو النهائي
في تاريخ اللعبة التي تعرف أنني
أحبها ، أحب لعبة Lynx Golf ، المسار القديم هو
المسار المفضل لدي للعب في الهواء الطلق هو
بطولتي المفضلة ، لذلك كان
أسبوعًا رائعًا لأكون جزءًا منه وكان لدي
القليل من الوقت  بداية بطيئة ولكن بعد ذلك
أعلم أنني استمتعت باللعب كثيرًا
وكانت عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
جوًا رائعًا واللعب الرائع كان
رائعًا حقًا فليتوود هو واحد من أكثر
اللاعبين شهرة واحترامًا في
الجولة وهو يبلغ من العمر 32 عامًا  الآن يستخدم
منصته لتنمية اللعبة ،
أكاديمية تومي فليتوود ، أول لعبة على الإطلاق كانت
في ساوثبورت ، مسقط رأسي ، ربما
نادي هول للغولف الذي كان المكان الذي
نشأت فيه حرفيًا طوال حياتي جونيور ، لقد أتيحت لنا
هذه الفرصة للتو لأخذ
قسم المبتدئين في الصيغة و  ما عليك سوى تطويره ،
أردنا تقديمه إلى المزيد من الأشخاص ، وكان
أهم شيء بالنسبة لنا هو
دفع الأطفال لمنحهم أحلامًا لمنحهم
التطلعات لمنحهم
الإلهام وتعليمهم لعبة
الجولف والأشياء الرائعة المتعلقة
باللعبة  من لعبة الجولف والسماح لهم ببناء
الثقة وبناء
شخصياتهم دفعهم إلى أقصى
حدودهم ولكن أثناء القيام بذلك ، استمتع
بها ومطاردتهم
بطريقة حماسية وعدم الخوف
من الفشل ، وهذا هو
شعارنا وهذا ما نحن  في محاولة
للقيام بالأكاديمية في المملكة المتحدة لإثبات أنها حققت
نجاحًا كبيرًا ، أطلقت فليتوود
مدرسة ثانية في دبي لخلق
فرص للأطفال هنا في
الإمارات العربية
المتحدة.  أنا من
أشد المؤمنين بلعبة الجولف وأريد
أن أرى أنني أريد أن أرى الخير الذي
يمكن أن تفعله وأن أحضره إلى المزيد والمزيد من
الناس مرة أخرى أريد أن أساعد الناس في
أي لعبة Walk of Life Golf هي ما
عشت  في ما عاشه الفريق بأكمله هنا في
الأكاديمية وأين كان ذلك
أطفالًا
يحلمون بجعلهم
يغرقون في بطولة كبرى أو
ما إذا كانوا أطفالًا يحلمون بالجوز
في مسيرة حياة أخرى مهنة
أخرى نقوم بها  نعتقد أنه يمكننا
استخدام مهارات الجولف وتعليمهم
لعبة الجولف وإحضارهم إلى
الأكاديمية وهذا سيساعدهم على طول
الطريق في أي Walk of Life
[موسيقى]